if you want to stay being a broke idiot
don't listen to this video and then
he'll be like be like here's the first
lesson for you do this and I know what
you're going to say blah blah blah blah
well here's what I say about that and
then he'll like flashes like fancy
[Music]
[__] so Sam texted me this morning and
he goes we did over a hundred million
views this year for the podcast and 100
million I thought he was wrong I was
like no way you got to go double check
that uh he was right we did and that is
way more than I thought we did that is a
Bonkers number I remember when we
started this podcast that sounded
completely crazy and what we wanted to
do today it's the end of the year we
wanted to look back and find what were
the key takeaways and lessons that we
learned from the 100 million views that
we had this year on the podcast so what
were the biggest things that stood out
when we look at the whole year what were
the biggest takeaways that we had uh Sam
where do you want to start yeah let me
let's just get the lead out the way
let's start with the numbers so I'm
going to give you I'll be transparent
about a bunch of numbers but not all but
a few um all right so in the last TW 11
so we have we have 10 days left in the
new year so I we're not actually at 100
million I think technically we're at 95
million but I think it's the past few
months it's been like five million a
week so on YouTube we got 80 million
downloads or 80 million views so far
that includes YouTube shorts which is
those pop off sometimes and we'll get
millions of views and so I don't put too
much emphasis on that but so uh YouTube
was around 80 million and then downloads
for the podcast the actual podcast so we
call we call everything the podcast but
there's basically we call it the RSS
feed that's Spotify iTunes whatever you
listen to your podcast
that was around 15 million and so
collectively we're at about 95 million
we did 131 episodes um which is a ton by
the way like this job it's fun but
that's a lot of work do you agree like
or or do you do you still think that
every episode is fun every episode's fun
to me and I feel like I'm able to um I
feel like I'm able to improvise well so
it is a lot of work but there are some
days some of our best episodes are ideas
we have 90 minutes before we record and
someone sends a text saying actually
what if we tried this and uh those turn
out really well sometimes and I think
it's because what we tried to do is make
this podcast the byproduct of the other
work we do so it's like the basic
business model is do interesting
business [__] so so invest in businesses
create businesses talk to interesting
people and then the Pod is just distill
the you know the the most interesting
10% that you're allowed to talk about
and go talk about it and so if we do
that right the pod's pretty easy when we
don't do that right then the Pod gets
pretty hard but it's kind of like
exercising like some days I don't want
to do it and then almost every single
time even if it's a bad episode or
something I didn't like I didn't love I
feel happy and I'm proud that I did it
so for me it's it's it's like exercise
um all right and I'll give you a few
more stats so do you want me to go
through the most pop the top three most
popular episodes yeah what are they all
right so we actually have two categories
so which is weird because the most
popular episodes on YouTube are not the
most popular episodes on podcast so
again RSS feed so the three most popular
episodes on megaphone that's what we
used to track this the first one is the
greatest businesses of all times scops
as a service work harder not smarter
Hack That was the the title the second
one was brainstorming chat GPT business
ideas with billionaire dares Shaw and
the third one shockingly I didn't think
this was going to be the top one or one
of the top ones was Nick Nick Huber how
to make millions from content without
selling ads that was the most popular
the top three most popular on podcast
the top three most popular on YouTube it
was the same one actually it was
brainstorming chat gbt business ideas
with the billionaire it was with darash
shad that has 450,000 views I don't know
this for sure I think he did something
dares did to manipulate this I think he
for sure emailed this out to his
audience I wouldn't be surprised if he
bought ads or did something because
dares loves to win and be number one so
he's number one on YouTube the second
most popular one on YouTube 10 years of
money wisdom in under 20 minutes 425,000
that is you by yourself and I think you
made that episode with YouTube in mind
is that right yeah made that as a
YouTube first and it worked and then the
third one was very recent it was
November 2nd how I bought a
multi-million dollar a carton business
for $0 391,000 views on YouTube Sarah
Moore and Shan and then I'll just say
the fourth one was Martin selli when we
interviewed him that had 257,000 views
um so that was a some of those were a
bit surprising what do you think about
that those make sense to me I mean each
of those is basically when I read the
title I'm like yeah I'd click i' click
that and that's basically what what
works on YouTube is I'd click that and
then you got to deliver on the promise
and so uh you know maybe this is maybe
this whole content thing is a lot
simpler and you just got to get the get
the titles right and then you work
backwards from there the content off the
title well and this this point is for
any content creator out there we you and
I this show we are kind of bastard
children of content creators so we
started without YouTube we only went for
podcast downloads on podcast apps I
think we had a YouTube channel but it
was really like you and I went to Best
Buy and we bought a camera and we just
set it there and we just uploaded it and
and so we didn't really care about it I
think we only started caring about a
year ago and uh what's crazy
is if you really want to do it the right
way or maybe not but the Really Right
Way is you start with one in mind and
you go all in on that we didn't go all
in on YouTube I don't think we should
have but but I understand the argument
that we should have because what works
on YouTube doesn't always work on RSS
feed and vice versa um and so speaking
of YouTube by the way do you want to
here here's a few more
stats so we added uh so we did 13
episodes we added about 250,000
subscribers sorry 210,000 subscri
subscribers we started the year at
150,000 and we ended with 360,000 and
you want to know the the biggest needle
mover besides actually caring about
YouTube uh do you want to know what it
was that got a
subscribers I'm gonna guess it's the
gentleman agreement is that not it the
the gentleman's agreement and so for all
the listeners out there here's another
takeaway when you hear a YouTuber say
click the Subscribe button and all that
and you hear everyone say that and gets
you you think it doesn't matter we saw a
there's a distinct point in the chart
where we asked people to subscribe and
it went up and so like it absolutely
works and so it's sort of like the thing
you know how people say why are you
buying ads on Facebook nobody uses
Facebook no one clicks ads nonsense that
is absolutely not
true I can't find this client info have
you heard of HubSpot HubSpot is a CRM
platform so it shares its dat dat across
every application every team can stay
align no out of sync spreadsheets or
dueling databases HubSpot grow
better yeah and actually that was one of
my takeaways for the year was when we
were like all right we should start
growing on YouTube what do we you know
what do we not like about what what's
stopping us from wanting to do that and
one of the things is dude I don't want
to be that guy who's like all right guys
if you like this video click the like
button and smash the Subscribe button
and turn on notifications as well it's
like oh God I got to turn in to you know
like inflatable arm YouTube guy and uh
you know like in front of the car
dealerships it's like that that W you
know inflatable arm balloon thing I was
like ah God I don't want to do this but
you had a really great idea of this idea
of the gentleman's agreement so
basically how do you do the cringe thing
in the non- cringe way right how do you
turn lemons into lemonade you did it
with the gentleman's agreement I think
we also did it recently with the thrill
of the shill where it's like yeah all
right look we want to have ads to
promote our businesses cool that's fine
and I think the audience gets that
that's fine but how do we not make this
an experience that's annoying for us to
do like sit down and record these like
shitty ad reads and then on the audience
side they just want to hit the skip
button it's like what would be neither
what would be fun for us and actually
fun for them to listen to and then when
we switch to the thrill of the shill I
feel like that was a good idea and I
think that's something that people
should do more of if you could pull it
off right um You should basically set a
standard of like no no no I'm going to
have my cake and eat it too and uh I
feel like we did that in two areas this
year and I feel like that's a that's
something worth worth remembering as we
go into next year of like all right what
would also be um instead of something
that's kind of lame or a bit of a drag
or just kind of extra work how do we
make it awesome for us and the audience
because it didn't take that much more
effort to do that it just took a little
bit of uh you know charm no and it
wasn't hard at all the problem was the
gentleman's agreement that we would
always tell people about it like faded
out like it got we forgot
it got not novel and we were like oh
[__] we have to come up with another one
and I like watch all these YouTube
videos and I just see one and I write
down and I'm like copying that copying
that and I just have forgotten to say it
so we screwed up by not being consistent
do you want to go like uh tip for Tat a
little bit and like just go through like
interesting things that you've learned
throughout the year yeah yeah all right
um I'll go first with one so this
podcast is steady Yeti this podcast is
the tortoise not the hair hair so it
grows very steadily you could put up
this chart from social blade that's like
your our YouTube growth and it's great
in that you know we started the year
under 150,000 we're ending the year
almost
400,000 but there's like no spikes this
thing is just a line that's just
creeping up like it you know like this
is like if my uncle goes for a hike this
is what it would look this is like what
it would look like it's it's a map it's
like this is his straa right here and so
I'm like what is this this is so
different than everything else do
because I am much more of a go for the
Home Run try to do something incredible
and then if it doesn't work or even if
it's like you know you find something
that's good ah just don't really follow
through and this is like a a leak in my
game in a way but I kind of took some
pride in this um let me give you some
examples so on Twitter we all joined
this group chat called the 100K club we
all had I don't know 10 to 20,000
Twitter followers and we all five or six
friends we all wanted to hit 100K we
independently had that goal and we all
did it we all surpassed it um but we all
did it very differently Nick Huber uh
Nick Huber did it and he's kind of
polarizing so he'll say controversial
[__] that uh he believes but he'll kind
of spice it up a little bit he knows
what he's doing he uses controversy to
grow and sa Hill is like every day I
wake up and I open a fortune cookie and
then I type it out whatever it was I'll
put that on Twitter and I'll do that
every single day and I'll do a read
every every Tuesday and Thursday and why
would I not it works and we're like why
would it not cuz it's so boring to do
that but he's he did it and he did it
and he grew the most out of all of us I
think he's like got a million and he did
it with like what I'll call more cookie
cutter stuff yeah feel good you know
kept it uh you know pretty safe no
controversy no real like I would say
like not much original you know
storytelling or or wisdom but more like
General best practices like kind of uh
you know stuff we've heard before but
packaged well he's posted so many videos
of children and just probably titled it
humans are amazing yeah like I love my
son I'm like I'm never gonna write that
[__] right like you know I looked at my
son and I was like Hey listen you're
never getting that all right you're
never getting that for me I'm not I'm
not using you for that and you're not
using me for that all right we're not
doing that but Jokes Aside you know sill
was more of
consistency and um and just put out uh
you know he was ready to hit base hits
and he just base hited his way to a
million and I did the opposite I didn't
have a schedule I didn't draft things I
didn't have a Ghost Rider I didn't do
anything I just had a I had probably six
tweets that went viral one was like this
Clubhouse thread one was about the
metaverse one was about Elon Musk one
was about whatever I just had a couple
of these things go go really really
viral and I would go weeks weeks without
even tweeting and then I would just do
that and and I got to maybe 350,000 and
so here's the lesson learned the jok's
on me in the end so this is kind of the
the long one to takeway is I was like
your boy's a home run hitter I just go
for the big swings I don't have to do
all that consistency BS I just come in
just mic drop with a viral thread and I
peace out and I was so happy with myself
I kind of looked up at the end of the
year I was like huh like the people who
did the consistency thing got way
further and had and did way less like uh
they didn't have to pull a rabbit out of
a hat to do it and I felt like I was
having to pull a rabbit out of a hat in
order to to get growth to happen and
because that's so hard I could only do
it so often the podcast because I do
this with you and you are a more
structured disciplined guy you're like
let's set recording dates and let's
never miss them and I'm like dude what
if we did like 10 episodes in the next
two days but then like you know if I'm
busy let's not do an episode like I
would have had had a totally different
schedule I would have such worse results
and when I look at this it's like damn
consistency wins again this brings me uh
it's five I think we're is this 550 or
520 so we're like 500 500 plus episodes
yeah 533 already said so we're 500 Plus
in it's a lot that's a lot and we record
like clockwork same time same days every
week no excuses and so I would have
never done some excuses we've had some
excuses
we have reasons yeah yeah yeah sickness
children and uh that's about it so all
right so but I guess the the this takes
me to one of the biggest lessons I
learned was through the podcast we met
Andrew Wilkinson people know about him
but I also met his business partner who
you know Chris and Chris said something
at a dinner that i' I've shared on the
podcast but it it was the question of
the year he goes you know somebody was
talking about some something they did
they failed they like oh but I and then
somebody else to like kind of Pat them
on the back was like w but you know you
learn so much and they're like oh my God
I learned so much yeah so many Lessons
Learned so many and Chris goes like
what and you would think for somebody
who went through this traumatic
experience and had so many lessons
learned that they would be like number
one this that's the most important
lesson number two this number three this
those lessons weren't at the tip of
their tongue in fact the lessons weren't
even in their head they learned actually
nothing and Chris correctly called it
out and I had never heard anybody
question this assumption that when
somebody says I failed but I learned he
was like you know I don't think people
really learn he goes and in fact some
people who when I ask them what they
learned they say something that tells me
they learned the wrong lesson and I
think that's what happened to me this
year on the consistency versus like big
home run virality thing I think I
learned the wrong lesson I was cursed by
the fact that I did go viral a few times
and I I did pass my kind of 100K goal
and actually the lesson was dude if I
just had consistently tweeted every
Monday Wednesday and Friday probably
would have took me 30 minutes I probably
be at a million followers instead and um
and so I think I learned the wrong
lesson and I think that Chris's question
of did you even learn the right lesson
from this experience it showed up
everywhere for me this year everybody I
talked to I realized uh you know more
people fell into that camp the outlier
was somebody who went through something
and had the right takeaway from it the
outlier was that well I would say to you
and this isn't a leading question but it
is for me when I ask myself this which
is is that even worth it is having is
being popular on social media even worth
it and I talk to a lot of people who are
significantly suc more successful than I
am in ter terms of traditional success
they' built bigger companies whatever
and they'll ask about getting popular on
social media and my immediate response
is like but why like you're doing you're
doing awesome and you could be private
that sounds way better and so I would
wonder is it even worth it to have a
million for you in your case actually
the answer is probably yes but that's
something that I always ask people when
they talk to me about social media I
think for a lot of people the answer is
no because it's almost the cliche
example of uh play stupid games Win
stupid prizes it's like if you play the
I want to be popular on social media
game you win the wonderful prize
of having a bunch of followers who you
know don't really know or care about you
and you basically turning your life into
a performance for them right so you sort
of win the stupid prize in the end for
me my like you know after a bunch of
soul searching it became very obvious
that the thing I actually wanted to do
the thing that would bring me the most
joy in my life is like if I get to be
kind of like one of these like thinker
guys it's like I think you know I don't
actually want to be Elon Musk I want to
be Tim Ferris and once I realized that
and that sounded very true for me I was
like okay then I got to do that I got to
go learn cool stuff I got to synthesize
you know information from a bunch of
places and then yeah which is super fun
for me and then I'm gonna try to teach
it and I like teaching it and I you know
I'll try to share it I'll try I like
sharing it why not I'm so excited about
the stuff that I'm figuring out I'd like
to create content and I'm good at
creating content so it's a good fit for
me and so um for me it is probably the
right game I wouldn't say being popular
on social media is the right way to
phrase it I think it is like uh getting
to be a thinker like get making that
your your actual job um but you're right
me me calling it popular on social media
it's like calling it a Creator like it
just it's like oh that's cute that's not
how I meant it but that's it sounds like
um all right the biggest thing I learned
this year and I have a bunch of them but
number one the biggest thing so I'll
I'll set the stage here so I think last
spring I do you remember what month it
is we were like all right uh I had I was
at the two so basically when I sold the
company the HubSpot I had like a twoe
deal where um I stock had a vest
whatever that ended in February and then
we had to renegotiate some stuff some
some contracts and I think we started
that when did we start that do you
remember which month end of April end of
April it didn't end until September is
that right did it was it September where
it ended something like that August
September so we go to negotiate this and
I'm a pretty soft guy I have known all
along that I'm bad at negotiating I
hard on the outside soft on the inside
yeah like I I just I'm not good with
uncomfortable conversations I uh I just
I don't love confrontation I want people
to think that I'm easy to deal with but
I leave a lot on the table I leave a ton
on the table and we go to negotiate this
contract and Sean you were like let me
take a lead on this and you did so many
things that I thought were the stupidest
thing
ever and I was like you're being being
rude this is stupid you're being like
you're asking for too much you're you're
being difficult you're in the weeds too
much why do you care about this one you
know it'd be like a five-page or eight
page contract and you're like this one
sentence guys we need to talk about it
like we need to change this word from
like uh uh you know like mandatory to
optional I don't even remember yeah like
it like you were like and I think we
probably had 10 revisions and I and we
had a we you and I had to hire a lawyer
to go through all this stuff and we
sweat the details so much in my heart I
was like everything about this is wrong
and you want to know something I was
wrong you were right you negotiated this
wonderfully and um I learned so many
things and I could summarize this in uh
something you said I think you said
someone told you which is the person who
could be most uncomfortable in a
negotiation will oftentimes win yeah I
think that I think that's it so the way
you said it isn't actually the way I
would say it so you said you know
whoever's more uncomfortable will win
and it's actually like the first thing
negotiat realize it's not about winning
like both sides want things usually
different things you have to make sure
both sides get what they want so that
both sides feel like they win but that
uh it is true that you have to be
willing to be uncomfortable for much
like almost like the definition of the
word uncomfortable for longer than
you're comfortable being uncomfortable
right that was the that's what I was
trying to say because you know um it's
very easy in the moment to say if I push
this button the pain stops and the
uncertain goes away and the item goes
off my to-do list and it's very tempting
to want to push that button well like
I'm not particularly that so at the
hustle we did Enterprise sales basically
so we you know $100,000 plus advertising
deals I wasn't particularly good at that
but one thing that I learned early on
was it's what for any salesperson it's
best to not be like a hard-hitting like
I'm gonna sell you this I'm gonna sell
you this instead you say all right so
what are you guys looking for like what
would what what are you trying to get
out of this um what do you need more
customers or you know you basically ask
them what they want and then you tailor
a solution or or or or position your
solution to fit their needs you did a
really good job of that you're like all
right HubSpot um tell me everything you
guys want and we'll try to accommodate
or or or I'll phrase my solution to fit
your needs and and and we you did a
really good job at that all right um so
let me do a simple
one this year my cash flow so my monthly
income I think went up by like 4 a half
X however I didn't I I was very focused
on making money and I didn't and I
normally don't care about like you know
expenses or you know it's like you know
that phrase it's like it's not how much
you make it's how much you keep that's
true I just don't really follow it very
well and the biggest expense sounds
always sounds smart the biggest expense
always is taxes and I didn't do a lot of
tax planning so this is a very simple
one one of my big takeaways for the year
is
um uh lesson learned again that taxes
are your biggest expense once you start
making real money
and I looked into a bunch of different
opportunities and at only at the end of
the year did I um do something smart
which was I know somebody very well who
is phenomenal at real estate they have a
very Niche application of real estate um
they crush it uh like I'm talking about
went from zero to owning a billion
dollars in real estate with no outside
Capital um in like you know eight years
type of thing and I watched them do that
Brick by Brick I know this this method
this like specific thing that they do
where they have a bit of an unfair
Advantage where why it works and I never
really asked them to participate in a
deal I was like uh you know they don't
take any external money so why not but I
know that we have a good really good
relationship so I was like maybe they
would take it so finally towards the end
of the year I was like hey can I like
deploy some Capital here because
if I can invest with you I think I'll
get a great return but also I'll get
that sweet sweet depreciation and um so
I will get a you know sort of a double
return on my side because I get the you
know returns for the property but I also
get the tax savings today I just started
doing it and it is so good it is so
smart and I'm I am so regretful that I
didn't take this more seriously earlier
and Jess ma came on the podcast and she
said it was her that triggered me to go
take action on this she goes I go do you
a bunch of she goes oh I want to talk
about what rich people do with their
taxes and we didn't even really get to
that in the episode but during the
preall I was like what do you mean by uh
we should talk about it like and she's
like well I think just the general thing
is that most entrepreneurs really don't
spend enough time on on their taxes and
I get it they want to build their
business but she's like if you just look
mathematically like this is going to be
you know between I don't know 30 to 50%
of all your income every year gets taxed
this way and 20 plus% of your gain
um of all your investment gains going to
get taxed this way she's like it's
financially irresponsible to not at
least spend five to 10 perent of your
time on this and then I did the math and
I was like 10% of my time would be five
full weeks of a year I was like there's
no way I'm going to do that but I was
like I should at least spend like two
one you know like something where I'm
actually focused hire like a did you do
like a tax strategist I talked to a few
but I you know the reality was it's not
that hard like the real real estate
really is the best way to do this
because what you do is you take um you
know you take Inc T income and you have
taxable income coming from one place you
take that cash you deploy that cash into
real estate and my you know my wife is a
real estate professional so we have we
can offset the active income and so you
you put the cash there now that cash is
going to grow in the property but you
got all this tax loss to wipe out your
your taxable income if that makes sense
so so you get cash on both sides but the
taxable income gets gets uh you know
reduced by using real estate so it
doesn't really take like I don't need to
do by the way it is hard it's hard to
find deals that are are good I mean like
I've that's the key like I knew this for
a long time I was like great what am I
gonna do go look for for plexes in
Missouri like I I don't have the time or
energy or expertise to do this then you
have a bunch of different like you know
fund manager type people you're like all
right I got to vet them and figure out
if they're any good and and and do a
couple deals with them and I could do
that in this case I was lucky that I had
a very longitudinal relationship with
somebody that I had seen do this with
their own money they're not a money
manager and so um and they get you know
far above average returns because of
what they do and so anyways that that
became you know the thing I'm GNA do so
anyways we we should talk more later you
should do this too I I'm like so
convinced that this is a good idea for
people in our position and I think most
of our friends in our Circle we're all
like internet money people and we we
like kind of suck at the the real world
money stuff yeah I suck at it um all
right I've got another one I've titled
this Loose Cannon loose results so for
the majority of my career I've been a
loose cannon I would say silly stuff and
it would get a reaction and I would get
results sometimes uh I got to put that
ashri sometimes uh result a laugh or
like I was in the media business we are
still in the media business which is
like I could I I can go the obnoxious or
blunt or ridiculous route and I can get
clicks and the problem with that is as
you get more popular you have to decide
are you going to go all in on that or
are you gonna not go all in in it or you
want to be this medium ground the medium
ground is bad and so here's here's an
example of someone who goes all in on it
Dave poroy the guy's a missionary he but
here's what here's what that means so he
says ridiculous stuff he had a sex
scandal this year uh regardless of what
the facts are I'm not even debating what
the facts of that of his issues were he
was accused of being um uh I I it might
have been like crazy like assault like
some really bad [__] and he went all in
on it and he came out with like and he
like he kind of I don't think he joked
about it but he like confronted it
headon but then there's other things
that he's done where he's like look I'm
so rich I can do all this stuff and but
there's a downside to that the upside is
he got lots of traffic he uh you know
whenever he goes through any typee of
Scandal he gets lots of views and
somehow I imagine he gets paid through
those ads the downside is obvious which
is you are now this guy where you've got
to live this life where you're this
loose canon guy you say whatever you
want and you're a huge Target then we've
gotten really close with Andrew
Wilkinson who is not a loose canon he
says some stuff uh bluntly but in and
he's a very honest guy but he's reserved
a bit more measured yeah he's more
measured we had um uh sad on the what's
what's sayed's last name balky uh balky
he's one of the best guests we've had
very measured the guy's only 32 or
something and he's in the ballpark of
being a billionaire he owns all these
companies and off air uh when I've hung
out with him he's a a little bit less
measured but on air he was def like he
was very like I look my reputation
matters I need to have a good reputation
and he cared about that stuff we also
had Kevin Ryan Kevin Ryan probably the
second or third most successful guy
we've had in the podcast very measured
uh very honest but very like
straightforward but also like
calculating uh Sarah Moore was another
person Sarah MOA Sarah MOA she
explicitly said I don't want to be
famous I'm only gonna be here and she
still said good stories but I'm sure
that she like her reputation was in mind
things like that and I think that um I'm
not willing to go the Dave poro route
for sure I don't want that flak I've
said very mild things and I'll get Flack
for it and I'm like yeah I just don't
want to live this life where I where I
go hardcore so anyway a takeaway is I've
actually wanted to pull back some public
Persona stuff not reveal certain numbers
I don't want to be a Target I don't want
to have to fight these battles I don't
get joy from that I used to get joy from
that and I would respond to haters
constantly online just prove like see
you can't talk [__] to me I'm like I'm a
real guy I read all the comments that's
stupid I don't want to be that person
that that that's a pretty big takeaway
you you've done a good job of like
you've not you've actually had a few
fires this year where you said some
stuff that you got called out on and you
didn't back down from it but you also
didn't engage in it I don't even
remember um there was a there was a time
where you criticized someone who worked
for you and it caused a little bit of a
spat on the
internet uh and I I don't remember
another time but I think that that's
what I'm referring to and in my head
when I'm hearing you say that or and
when I'm seeing that I'm like I want to
stay out of this I don't want any of
this drama I don't want I don't want I
don't want the stress you know we've
seen it with chath a bit where he put
himself out there and he's done some
contradictory things and he's taken a
lot of flak and I respect that he's like
owned up to it and he like faces it
headon I don't want to live that life I
thought I did I don't as we've gotten
more popular I I for sure do not want to
live that life and I prefer to be more
private now than I was in the
past that's a good one um I have kind of
a related one
so one of the best meetings I had this
year was with James Courier James
Courier for those don't know he is the
founder of something called nfx which
stands for Network effects they
basically they have like I don't know a
billion dollars of assets under
management they they invest in Tech
startups he's been in he's a Silicon
Valley OG so he's been building
successful tech companies for like you
know 20 years or something like that
yeah he's had I think multiple hundred
million doll plus exits correct and
super fun guy so I go to his office so I
drive down to Palo Alto I don't usually
leave the house but for James I'm there
and literally it's just me and him in
the office I was like where's everybody
else he's like we don't really even have
that many people but also yeah nobody's
coming to work anymore everyone works
from home so it's me and him in his
office for a couple
hours and uh he shared with me a piece
of advice that really stuck with me and
I started seeing ever something I hadn't
really thought about so he goes he goes
can I give you some unsolicited advice I
was like please and he goes you know
today he drew this like line on the
Whiteboard he's like he goes he goes I
really like what you guys are doing with
your show uh but I don't know like where
you go from here he's like you're kind
of in the middle he's like meaning if I
think about really upm Market he's like
you know when we make content we're not
making content that we don't want a
million views if we did a million views
on a piece of content we probably made
the wrong piece of content he goes
because what I'm doing and if fact he's
like I'm trying to invest in you know
whatever it's the next Airbnb the next
Twitter the next whatever so he's like
like I need the most ambitious Founders
in the world who are building you know
like Venture back tech companies to read
our stuff really care about it and think
when I'm going to raise money I'm gonna
go to nfx and he's like so you have us
and a16z and others that are trying to
be really up Market because we're trying
to attract a certain quality of founder
of which there's only you know a smaller
pool but they also care about different
things they're only going to you know
they don't want to hear about the the
vending machine side hustle like we'll
we'll be like oh dude this 18 vending
machines he's making 22k a month isn't
that sick and like he doesn't care about
that they're trying to get you know only
people who are going to like disrupt the
healthare system or some [__] like that
I don't know so such a big idea who even
knows what it means by the way I would
disagree with him I I think that the I I
think they care enough to listen but not
enough to actually do anything about it
you know what I mean oh yeah the vending
machine thing actually you're right
because I meet a lot of these people and
they're like pretty fascinated by like
uh the economics of stuff that's outside
of their world cuz there business nerds
I think they actually care enough to be
entertained by it but that's but that's
about it but like then you have on the
other end of the spectrum you have you
know let's say and I I love Gary Vee but
you know Gary Vee is basically like
motivation grind like hey you gota like
his content will be literally he's like
I'm gonna pull up to this garage sale
and I'm gonna flip this VHS for you know
on eBay and imagine if I did that every
day you could you you that could be your
hustle and it's like so I could make you
know hundred grand a year it's like I
kind of job can do that but this is I
guess the the entry level of
Entrepreneurship it's like and he so he
has a huge audience which I respect by
the way but if you do it Gary you know
like what's the deal for like the best
investments Gary's made I think came
from his peers like his friends he hung
out with not like his listeners in that
way right not his fans right um and he
probably like I I shouldn't speak for
him but I guess like it's very easy if
you're in that position to be like it's
great because I get huge numbers but
I'm not necessarily it's not like a
two-way thing I'm not learning back from
my audience as much maybe I'm you know
I'm happy to sign autographs and take
selfies but I'm not try I I'm not
excited to go have dinner with five
people in this group because I don't
feel like it's gonna you know iron's not
sharpening iron there right like I'm a
black belt I'm more hanging out with
white belts and so I kind of want to
when I'm trying to spar I want to spar
with black belts anyways so he's like
you have a decision to make you're in
the middle right now with my first
million you kind of have a foot in both
camps and he's like it's going to be
very tempting for you to go down market
and he's like don't do it he's like go
if anything go up market and in the long
run you're are going to want you're
going to be more interested in the
topics that those people are interested
in you're going to not want to keep
saying the same like beginner level
here's how you you know literally here's
how you make your first million here's
how you get here's how you should quit
your job and here's how you get a
startup idea and here's how you in
corporate an LLC like you're not going
to want to make that content as you grow
and he's like you should
steer up AR he like my only advice to
you is that um I think that was so smart
and so I don't even know why he said
that to me because who's even thinking
about that I wasn't even thinking about
it but now like I'm just gonna give you
an example Alex heru I think is in one
hand absolutely killing the content game
I think Alex is awesome I think he's
super super talented but I think he's
making a mistake in that he goes very
down Market I'm just going to read you
some titles of his last of videos he's
posted in the last like two months okay
how to make so much money it makes you
sick
um how to get rich this Black Friday
watch this if you're tired of being
broke uh the real reason your business
isn't
growing
um a bunch of these right so like I
don't want to you know pick on these but
these are more down Market Video
Concepts and they'll get views for sure
and like the comments will kind of show
you people like oh my God you changed my
life you're my hero blah blah blah and
like it's not that he's not doing a
service for those people
however I I look at that and I think for
me the game I want to play is definitely
going to be not to go down Market to
resist the temptation to try to create
that content and to focus on creating up
aret content which is going to have a
lower view count number but it's going
to have a higher value per viewer and
more of the audience and the it's like
I'm creating a magnet I'm not creating
an audience I'm creating a magnet with
my content and I want to attract the
right people and so uh anyways that was
a big lesson or takeaway for me that I
wouldn't have otherwise thought about
yeah I think so like sometimes some of
the contractors who work on this podcast
will suggest ideas because they're just
looking at like YouTube analytics and
I'm like no I I I eight eight out of the
10 Things I I don't think would would
work if Apple sold iPhones for five
dollar they'd sell more units too right
like but if you're building an upm
Market brand or if you're Louis Vuitton
like you don't want to go down Market
there's another guy we met uh and we
fall victim to it as well I don't want
to act like our [__] don't stink but
like even though you and I will fight it
like sometimes we will correct the only
reason this lesson resonates is because
it's something I'm wrestling with right
if I have a solved problem I don't
really care about it it doesn't stand
out as a big takeaway because I didn't I
didn't have the problem in the first
place this is a problem I have so I'm
trying to figure out where to go and
this advice was very helpful um there's
another guy who does this have you seen
this guy on Instagram the genius
CEO yeah yeah
he he's in Austin right now I think he's
so funny I think he's so fny so funny so
like I find him hilarious and like when
I met him I can't tell if his Instagram
is a joke like it's like there's a lot
of like nuggets in there but he'll be
he'll be like Bad Bunny is only making
30 million dollars a year what a [__]
move we're gonna teach this guy how to
make a billion like he'll like insult
these people and it's pretty funny yeah
he'll be like uh he goes th this product
this product is going to bust faster
than a bunch of you Chumps out there
there so let me tell you how I would do
it I was like who like what a hook um
but so we met this guy in real life in
real life total sweetheart and very
smart guy right super nice dude humble
whatever and then I'm like and I'm like
why do you have this like ridiculous
mustache your fingernails are painted
you got this like crazy chain in a Gucci
purse but like well he looks like a
celebrity he's like a tall good-looking
guy he looks like an IG like like a a
male IG thought but you're in person
you're a totally respectable humble nice
guy dad and he was like oh yeah I
created this character he's like I
realized like what hits on IG is going
to be like fancy cars fancy [__]
six-pack abs hot girls and so he's like
you know I just do that it's my
character and I built a following so
he's got 200,000 followers on here his
content is hilarious it's so funny he's
but he's selling uh you know FBA you uh
you know basically like I made my
Millions selling Drop Shipping basically
you know doing FBA Brands uh you know
you're if you want to stay being a broke
idiot don't listen to the studio and
then he'll be like be like here's the
first lesson for you do this and I know
what you're gonna say blah blah blah
blah well here's what I say about that
and then he'll like flashes like fancy
[__] he's like this is a video of me
buying this Von CLE uh you know necklace
it's so funny any questions and I'm like
wow what is happening with this guy but
I think he's also gonna be trapped in
the down Market thing right he's selling
a mastermind you got to go pay to get
into he's going to make millions of
dollars doing this but I don't think
he's got any like you know I don't think
he's got any way out you know that that
is a he's cornered himself in that way
sure sure yeah I he's a good follow he's
very funny um all right let me give you
another one so the biggest takeaway that
I I want people to have from this
podcast we've done it now for three or
four years is and and and at first I uh
like I'll go get a haircut and they'll
be like so what do you do for work and I
was like oh I do this I do that I I work
on this podcast and they're like What's
the podcast about and I'm like well it's
called my first million but it's not
like the title is in acccurate and and
I'll I'll explain what it's about and
what what I what I tell people is that
look we've had multi multi-billionaires
on this show we've had employees at
companies on on this show I think what
we care about is people who create a
path and they do it not necessarily like
I don't necessarily think just because
you are a billionaire you are
particularly better than anyone else
like what I care about is someone who
says I'm gonna be great at this weird
type of art intentionally choose a game
so they choose a game with intention and
then they play the [__] out of that
their game right that is at the
description because that's what it is
for me that's exactly it and so for
example the guy I talk about all the
time Brett Adcock he's not like me he's
like well I'm gonna raise a billions
billions of dollars and try to create a
500 billion dollar company I'm I'm
inspired by that but I will never I
don't want to do that or even this
example we just gave the genius CEO he
chose to play that game and he's playing
the [__] out of it I respect that I
don't want to do that but I I I kind of
admire people who intentionally choose
their game and then play the [__] out of
I admire the hell out of it or we've had
John cougan John kugan um started
soilent which scaled to be a fairly
large business he's got another company
and now he's like a full-time content
creator he has a a YouTube channel and
he it's beautifully done he's doing it
wonderfully and then we've had Rob
dierck on we've had lared Hamilton on
guys who aren't the Silicon Valley type
of Lifestyle but they kill it and
whatever they do and I admire all of
them equally and so the takeway that
I've had which is there's a million ways
to get to where you want to go or
there's a million ways to get to certain
way to a certain place and for a lot of
these people it's money but there's
still a million ways to get there and
there's you shouldn't just like for
example when I moveed to San San
Francisco I was like you have to raise
VC you have to do this you have to do
this but then we meet meet Sayad
who I imagine yeah I imagine he's worth
500 to a billion dollars he started a
WordPress blog which sounds crazy stupid
if you don't know what you're talking
about which I didn't turns out that
killed it then he bought tons of gas
stations now he owns 50 different
WordPress plugins collectively that does
over 100 million in Revenue he's a young
guy in Florida not even a cool part of
Florida he's not Miami I think he's in
like Tallahasse or I forget where like
somewhere in Florida yeah no disrespect
Tallassee I see Ari but there's just
there's just people just listen to this
podc like oh man their Hometown where
they grew up dude Lauderdale I don't
care I'm
I'm from St Louis all right I could say
these things I'm not from a cool place
so all the baltimores out there you know
like I Feel Love shout out to the tears
tear seek cities out
there it's it's objectively not like the
place to be and but what I'm saying is I
appreciate the hell out of people like
that and learning about all of these
different ways and my biggest takeaway
from this year and doing the podcast
which is there's a lot of different ways
to do it you just have to choose where
you want to go and you got to choose
what rules you're willing to play by but
there's 's not one way to do it and I
wouldn't even I wouldn't even go as far
as to say there's one that's likely in
fact if I had to say that I would say
the one that's likely to get there is
starting a small Services business and
just growing it over 50 years and paying
yourself a good salary after year 10 and
doing that for for decades which is not
at all what I would have expected you
know it's just a a normal small business
owner that does it for a long time is
significantly more likely to have a
higher income and die rich than any
other way but there's a lot of different
ways to do it and that's one of the
things I appreciate uh appreciate about
doing this
podcast that's a great one and I do
think that
that's the if you zoom out that is kind
of the point of the Pod the point of the
Pod isn't saying do X or do y it's check
this out you can do X here's how that
works you could do y here's how that
works you can do Z here's how that works
and by the end of it you're either going
to be in one of two positions some
people hear all that and get overwhelmed
they don't know where to go there's too
many too many paths too many
possibilities um they it sort of
paralyzes them but I hope that's not
most people I think for most people the
net reaction is kind of like wow winning
and being successful is this thing that
feels scarce if you're not around it
right like where I grew up I didn't know
any business people nobody in my family
was a business purp person no not my
cousins not my aunts not my uncle none
of them did businesses you're raised in
Tallahassee born in Oklahoma and uh
and so you know I wasn't just Ari just
flicked me off or making of tassy by the
way and so so you know I I wasn't around
it it seemed like this far away thing
that I didn't really even understand
there was no map and I thought maybe
there's one path but I don't know it and
I'm not invited to that to that party
and then my hope is that if you listen
to this podcast you're going to hear
over the course of a year a hundred
different examples of ways to win and
how they work and at that point it's
just a matter of choosing and all of a
sudden winning and success becomes this
thing that instead of being scarce and
difficult is abundant it's everywhere
and it's right at your fingertips if you
just start start doing whatever sounds
most intriguing to you and then you just
keep playing the game you know it'll it
will work out for you um that's I think
that's what the Pod ultimately does for
people good I hope it does um I have one
more do you have one more uh you go all
right my last one so we had Scott
Galloway on Scott Galloway is a guy who
he he sat on the Pod he goes I'm worth
over100 million and he also said in that
same sentence I'm deeply afraid of
running out of money we had Morgan howel
on most recently and he said something
like um he knows that you shouldn't
necessarily set goals for money and he
knows like objectively he's got enough
that he likely won't ever run out and he
knows that he shouldn't check his net
worth but then also so we pressed him on
it and he was like but of course like if
I'm laying at bed at night like just
because I know what I'm supposed to do I
still wonder what it would like be like
to have more and I don't think we've
ever had anyone on the podcast maybe
Jack Smith maybe Jack Smith but Jack
Smith's like a freak but I don't think
we've ever had anyone on the podcast
regardless of what they have they don't
want more and that sounds like a really
negative thing of like uh uh what you
have enough why do you need more why do
you need to achieve this and that I
think it should be the opposite and I
think the takeaway is no matter what you
have you're always going to feel that
there's another level and that you
should one up and I don't think that's a
depressing takeaway I think the takeaway
should be you will always want more
accomplishments more achievements and
that is okay that is totally okay and
that is normal and just expect that
wherever your goal is once you achieve
it you're going to feel satisfied only
for a short amount of time and then
you're going to want to achieve more and
that's basically 95 or no I would say
say 99% of the time that's true and
that's okay it's okay to want more right
uh I think there's a healthy way to go
about it and there's an unhealthy way to
go about it I would say Scott probably
has unhealthy ways I would say I have
unhealthy ways and I think you can
change those unhealthy ways to healthy
ways but no matter what you have you
will accomplish whatever your goal is
and you will get there it'll take six
months and you'll
say what's next how do I do it again how
do I do more and just expect that that's
going to
happen yeah I think when people hear
that it sounds like you know sounds
wrong or sad or bad or something like
that but another way of looking at that
same thing is um the concept of infinite
and finite games and so the my my
understanding of it I haven't spent a
ton of time on this but my understanding
of it is a very simple understanding is
a finite game is one where you play for
the result so you play in order to
achieve an outcome and you're hoping to
get to that
outcome that's the purpose of it and
then an infinite game is one where you
play for the sake of playing and so you
you play because you want to play now if
you look at that in practice so for
example for me basketball is something I
I consider like an infinite game right
like I I play because it's so fun to
play and I want to play and my goal is
not to like win and stop my goal is to
win but I I wouldn't stop if I won
because but not because it's like greed
it's like well winning is a is baked it
the scoreboard makes the game more
interesting and in a in a small burst
yes of course we're trying to win the
four you know by the end of the fourth
quarter I want to have the higher score
But ultimately like you know hey all
right let's run it back let's play again
let's play again let's play till our
legs fall off is is basically how it's
always felt for me and that's the
closest thing I felt to an infinite game
until kind of business came in and it's
actually very very similar it's like I
like having a scoreboard it makes it
more fun to play when you do keep score
but I'm not trying to get to a result to
I'm not doing work to get to a result
and then I'm going to stop working it's
I like playing I plan to keep playing
I'm playing for the sake of playing and
but the scoreboard makes playing a lot
more interesting and fun and intense and
that should be the takeway that way the
takeway is that because I had the I
previously had the if I get to this I
will not feel stressed and I won't work
anymore the reality is I still felt
stress I felt less stress though there's
no no doubt about that I felt a lot less
stress
and six months later I was like but I
have to go and do something I I feel
like a piece of [__] just sitting here
and I feel good contributing by way why
do you think you uh if I just said why
do you still feel stressed why do you
think you feel stressed even after the
event because I think that I I the the
stress I I think that I well like to get
like therapeutic it's all baked into
some type of childhood trauma and and
that just takes years to like unwind but
why does it uh why part of the stress is
comparing yourself to others um and so
you want to achieve more and also
wanting more stuff which is uh what do
they say desire is Hell or desire is
pain yeah or desire is suffering so
wanting more stuff um which I try to
combat by just I'm like no that won't I
try to like say this won't make me happy
uh comparing myself to others wanting
more stuff and also just wanting to get
rid of a chip on my shoulder right I'll
offer you a different answer that might
be true for you I don't know if it is or
not but I I think I I believe this is
more true because I hear a lot of people
talk about it it's
like uh childhood trauma it's like all
right well nothing I could do about that
that's literally the past it's written
and it sounds like it's a it's a long
unpacking process I don't want to do
that like I I still got suit cases over
here I haven't unpacked from vacations
I've been on like I just don't want I'm
not trying to unpack years of childhood
trauma similarly it's like oh I have to
like stop the feeling of Envy or desire
oh my God wired as an animal
sound actually think there's a answer
which um emotion the emotions you feel
are much like muscles it's basically
you've had a lot of practice at
stressing so what happens is people
practice feeling a certain way and they
don't think about it as practice but
what does it mean when you do something
all the time or regularly you are
habituating yourself or practicing doing
that you're getting reps at doing it and
then sudden one day suddenly they change
the the environment and they think that
all that practice and that muscle that
they've basically developed and
practiced and repped daily will just go
away and this new muscle called content
content and happiness will appear
because the money the the bank balance
in your you know Bank of America account
has
changed no way right and so I would
actually say it's the opposite if you
want to change that feeling it's not the
money it's you have to find away on a
daily basis to practice having that
feeling you want to you want to feel
happy you got to practice happy you want
to feel content and peaceful you got to
practice content and PE peaceful you got
to practice that more than you're
practicing anxiety and fear and stress
and all these other things and So for
anybody out there who's listening Sam is
absolutely right your feeling is not
going to change but I don't think it's
because of these like deeply rooted
psychological and historical reasons a
simpler example a simpler explanation
might be that I've really just gotten a
lot of reps practicing one thing and
therefore that's easy and familiar and
habitual for me and I got to start prac
ing the other the same thing happened
when we sold the milk Road I talked to
Ben and I was like Ben how's it feel
first kind of big exit for you and he's
like honestly it doesn't feel like I I'm
kind of disappointed like it doesn't
feel like very much like it doesn't I
don't feel that much and I go he's like
maybe it's because maybe if the number
was bigger maybe this right he started
going down that path and I was like no
dude it's because you're trying to feel
like this kind of Victorious Joy how
many days out of the year the last 365
days did you feel that like zero is you
let yourself feel that zero and so what
do you think all of a sudden today
you're going to turn on and be really
good at feeling that like no dude it's
practice like you if you want to feel
that we got to do that regularly so that
that muscle's there and uh do you uh did
you come up with this theory on your own
or did you steal it uh Tony Robbins when
I was at that event he has a similar
thing he calls it your emotional home he
goes everybody's got an emotional home
he's like cuz he's like he's like look
watch watch this raise your hand if
you're somebody who uh you know
sometimes gets a little pissed off
everybody raise your hand he's like
raise your hand if sometimes you are
just super silly having fun being
playful everybody raises their hand he's
like okay so we're capable of both you
are not like just an [__] or just a
super nice easygoing guy we all
fluctuate and he's like but it is true
that we have an emotional home it's the
place like your home it's the place you
spend the most time and he's like if
your emotional home is that you are
stressed out it doesn't matter if you
sell your company for a billion dollarss
if you did if you grinded for seven
years you were stressed all the time
you're not just going to become a
different guy all of a sudden right
because that's your emotional home but
he's like good news is you can move it
he's like you can move it if you
basically practice it right and he's
like so we wna basically um you know you
don't want to wait for the for things to
happen to feel a certain way he's like
you want to have it on call that you can
change the way you feel like that fast
can you do that can you change the way
you feel that fast and a lot of the
events of Tony Robbins and the reason
why people feel like almost like he's
manipulative is because he literally is
manipulating the way you feel he's
showing you that like you can change the
way you can go from focused to jubilant
to um Zen and calm and reflective to
motivated and inspired in like a 30
minute span just by the way he's kind of
prompting you and uh the trick obviously
is to learn to do that yourself so that
you now are in control of your own mood
you're the master of your own mood and
that's that was B that became a big
Focus for me after that event that was
my big takeaway from the event was that
and then I started practicing that for
last like six seven years I wish you had
come up with that on your own because
you don't realize it but one of the big
three like uh psych uh you know so
there's like Sigman Freud and then
there's two other guys who are
considered like the Godfathers of 19th
century of like psycho analy analytics
and all this stuff and one of the guys
is Alfred Adler and he's got there's a
book called the courage should be
disliked that's quite good and what you
are saying is exactly in parallel with
what he has said about like happiness
and like it's like well you're anxious
because you're choosing to be anxious
and you don't you're not choosing to do
this other thing and he's got this whole
book on it but you you didn't realize it
but you've just discovered relative you
know the theory of relativity uh Ju Just
like Albert Einstein you didn't even
know about it so you're kind of like one
of the big three Adler guy sounds like a
smart guy yeah like I like the sound of
this I'm gonna go check this out so so
so that's you um all right where do we
go from here is that it that's it I
think we wrap it up uh thank you for
everybody for listening you know those
those views ain't going to view
themselves it's because of you guys but
you
know we we we just talked about wanting
more Sam are you satisfied are we are we
done do we have enough subscribers would
you say we only have 360 you know Mr
Beast has 100 100 million we're nothing
we're losers I'm anxious about this and
so if you've enjoyed this episode if you
enjoyed any of our episodes subscribe on
YouTube also go to Spotify go to podcast
the the Apple version And subscribe
could go to therapy and stop wanting
this or you could just click the button
and make us feel happy which
one save us years of therapy and just
click
subscribe and just say you're welcome in
the comments and we know when you say
you're welcome it's because you saved us
years of therapy you just gave us what
we wanted instead all right that's the
[Music]
pod